[Music]
in ursula k le guin's novel the tombs of
ottawan
one of the characters who were
introduced to rather early on who is of
the same age as the main character arha
or tenor
is this girl pentha and she's
in some respects on a similar track
although there's some very important
differences
as arja is arha is the
reincarnation of the priestess of the
the uh unnamed ones of aatuan right
and pentha has been
given to the religious establishment
she's going to be in the temple of the
god kings
so there's been for both of them
a appropriation from their family life
they live together in a common area and
they share a lot of
experiences in common although as we're
going to see
there are some things where they are
very very different not just because of
their characters but also because of
what happens to them
we encounter her first as a sort of
playmate or explorer with young arja
she doesn't have you could say the
force of character she's called gentle
at one point she recognizes a certain
passivity in herself and this shows up
in the very first vignette that we have
where
penthouse says oh you know we've got to
get back it's time to
leave and arya says no no let's stick
around and who gets punished poor little
pentha
but there's there's a an important role
to her
in this story through her
aarha learns as leguin will put it the
existence
of unfaith and i think that's an
interesting
phrase to use right there
it's it's not the existence of non-faith
the lack of faith of
the contrary to faith but something
different and this is expressed through
the different desires and the different
perspectives
that penthouse brings into the story in
part by
communicating them in conversation
with arja so
there's a lot of really important stuff
happening in here and and we can chart
out this involvement by looking at the
several different places where she
comes up in the story she doesn't get an
awful lot of space but she gets some
so the first one is in chapter 2
where they are playing around on the
wall arha said come on and let the other
girl down the hill around out of sight
of the big house to the wall
now they sat on top of it 10 feet up
their bare legs dangling on the outside
looking over the flat plains that went
on and on to the east and north and then
they have a conversation that we'll come
back to
in a moment but what happens there
penthouse smiled she was a soft
comfortable looking girl and she talks
about being by the sea they play around
the the eunuch manon comes around and
they make fun of him right and then
a little bit later penthouse says we
ought to go back and it says the weaving
mistress might tell thar soon it'll be
time for the nine chance arja says i'm
staying here you stay too
they won't punish you but they will
punish me said penta in her mild way
arha did not reply pent aside and stayed
and she does indeed get punished he gets
told to strip and scourged with a whip
that actually draws some blood
arha doesn't get punished so this is
sort of emblematic of their the
difference in their relationship and you
can tell that arha is a much more
forceful person penta kind of goes along
with things
we'll come back to the
discourse that they have in chapter two
in chapter four
pentha is bringing apples to arja
and at first she has to kind of go
through this make-believe
mumming right she pretends like she's
just you know wandering around here we
go um one morning penta came to see her
from the porch arhasara approached the
small house with a careless purposeless
air as if she just happened to be
wandering that way if r had not spoken
she would not have come up the steps but
arja was lonely and spoke penta made the
deep bow required of all who approached
the priestess of the tombs then plopped
down on the steps below arha and made a
noise like poof
she'd gotten quite tall and plump
anything she did turned her cherry pink
she was pink now from walking and she
gives arha these apples she also
and i won't go through the entire story
here but she recounts this very funny
story about things happening you know
one one thing leading to another and
there's you know caricatures and uh you
know pretending to have somebody else's
voice involved in it and they have a
great laugh together and this is penta
bringing her
not just apples but a kind of
joy
we also see penthouse being talked about
in the aftermath of the
earthquake in
chapter 11
where arja is reflecting on what's going
on and she says what will they say
what will they think poor pentha
she might have to become the high
priestess of the god king now and it was
always she who wanted to run away not i
maybe now she'll run away
tenor smiled there was a joy in her that
no thought nor dread could darken that
same joy that had risen in her waking in
the golden light so we don't know
actually what happens to penthouse in
this story what we do know is that there
is
an acceptance but also a rejection
of the religious establishment and the
religious path that is being sent out
set out for her
and what we know about penthouse desires
is that she she didn't choose the path
that she has been
placed on any more than arhat did
and this is uh quite important here so
we find that um
why you know why is penthouse there well
her her family gave her essentially
to the um
the establishment and and that's you
know what she's
stuck with but she wants to
to live she wants to to see to do
to enjoy things she says at one point
what i really like the most is eating
you know and that's a very basic
function for us human being something
that we ideally can all take
pleasure in you know she says you're
strong i wish i was strong i just like
eating
though
and
earlier on
in in chapter 2 penthouse says i'd like
to see the sea
and arja says what for and penthouse
says
i don't know what for
i i'd just like to see something
different it's always the same here
nothing
happens and then
arha says all that happens everywhere
begins here oh i know
but i'd just like to see some of it
happening
so
there is a recognition on penthouse part
that okay all this religious stuff
there's something to it
but it doesn't really
fit me
i i can't buy into
it as as something that i would you know
have a connection
with and a little bit later
we find
this this being discussed
penthouse says i was the sixth girl my
mother and father had they couldn't
bring up so many and marry them all off
so they brought me to the god king's
temple and dedicated me they had too
many novices there because pretty soon
they sent me on here
maybe they thought i'd make especially
good priestess but they were wrong about
that and and are says would you rather
not have been a priestess
and penthouse says would i rather of
course i'd rather marry a pig herd and
live in a ditch i'd rather anything than
stay buried alive here all my born days
with a mess of women in a perishing old
desert where nobody ever comes but
there's no good wishing about it because
i've been consecrated now and i'm stuck
with it now notice the next thing that
she says though
i do hope in my next life i'm a dancing
girl in auburn because i will have
earned it and so what we've got here is
is she wants to
enjoy vitality she wants to see
new things she actually talks about
ships at one time that she saw
sailing and they were something new
because they weren't just cargish
ships so that that's what pentha
is doing and she's stuck in this
religious life that isn't particularly
appealing and here
is where are
first encounters what leguin in the next
chapter chapter 5 will call
the existence of unfaith expressed by
her friend pentha
so how does this this uh work she she
asked doesn't the temple mean anything
to you
pentha always submissive easily bullied
did not take alarm this time
oh i know your masters are very
important to you she said with an
indifference that shocked arya that
makes some sense because you're their
one special servant you weren't just
consecrated you were especially born but
look at me am i supposed to feel so much
awe and so on about the god king he's
just a man even if he does live in
a palace 10 miles around with gold roofs
he's about 50 years old and he's bald
you can see it in the statues i bet he
has to cut his toenails just like any
other man i know perfectly well he's a
god but i think he's going to be much
more godlier after he's dead
and so this is kind of shocking to argue
you don't you don't take the religion
seriously and notice that penthouse does
and doesn't she's willing to see
things as they are and still acknowledge
well people think this is quite
important
arja says to her then well what about
the old powers that i serve right and
um arja agreed with penta she secretly
she'd come to consider the self-styled
divine emperors of car god as upstarts
false gods trying to filter the worship
due to the true and everlasting powers
but there was something underneath
penthouse words with which she didn't
agree something wholly new to her
frightening to her
she had not realized how very different
people were how differently they saw
life she felt as if she'd looked up and
suddenly seen a whole new planet hanging
huge and populous right outside the
window
one in which the gods did not matter she
was scared
by the solidity of penthouses unfaith
and she strikes out now notice before we
look at the strikes out
what's going on there arja is being
shocked
out of a kind of we could call it
dogmatism
about the world assuming that everybody
buys into what you
believe in
what you've been brought up to
believe in
and so this is a very important turning
point arja then says to her
that's true my masters have been dead a
long time they were never men do you
know penta i could call you into the
service of the tombs she spoke
pleasantly as if offering her friend a
better choice
the pink went right out of penthouse
cheeks yes you could but i i'm not the
sort that would be good at that why
i am afraid of the dark
ara made a little sound of scorn but she
was pleased she'd made her point
penthouse might disbelieve in the gods
but she feared
the unnamable powers of the dark as did
every
mortal
soul
so penta doesn't have complete unfaith
but what she has isn't really faith it's
more
fear
than
belief
or commitment or anything like that
this is incredibly important for arja
because it helps her recognize what is
going on in the very next chapter
where she is dealing
with uh castle
right she's we we find out that since
our had learned from gentle penta of the
existence of unfaith and had accepted it
as a reality even though it frightened
her she'd been able to look at castle
more and more steadily
and to understand her
castle had no true worship in her heart
of the nameless ones or of the gods she
held nothing sacred but power so this
arms are
against this essentially malevolent
other priestess who has much more uh
at her disposal than ara does so penta
provides her with something that winds
up being very helpful with her without
even
meaning to and that's that's kind of the
way of penthouse
we don't know what ends up happening to
her in in the book at least
is penta going to be happy or unhappy
she seems to be able to be
more or less content even though she's
got longings that can't be
easily satisfied in the religious life
that she has but perhaps
she'll run away we don't really know
but we do know that she's important to
the story
you